We have a voicemail number.
That number is two, one nine two.
David P here's an interesting question about
how I would handle a particular interpersonal
scenario.
Take a listen.
Uh, hi David.
Uh, I had a question, kind of a philosophical
question to ponder about AB.
Um, and it's, um, if someone, uh, you know,
an acquaintance, uh, who is a big admirer
of yours.
Okay.
Uh, you found out later that they were rapist
and murderer, right?
How would you respond to that?
Would you shut them out completely?
Um, would you, uh, try to, you know, get,
get further details on, on exactly what, what
they did?
Uh, would you try to understand or what, I'm
just, I'm curious.
Listen, I have no idea.
This has never happened to me before.
I've never found out that an acquaintance
or friend or something is a rapist or a murderer
and I don't know what would happen.
I mean it's, I could give you some answer.
I could say, Oh, I would definitely cut them
out of my life.
I could never have contact with him again.
Or I could say, you know, listen, I would
try to understand and if it was far enough
in the past at the time when they were really
a different person than I, I have no idea.
I think the details probably would matter.
My guess is that there are people in our audience
who, listen, they're there.
There must be people in our audience who are
acquainted with maybe not murderers, but,
um, more than likely, at least some people
in the audience, the audience is big enough
where there's probably people acquainted with
rapists.
I don't know.
I'd be curious to hear from others what a,
it was like when something like that was revealed.
I don't.
I think that, you know, this is like when
people say if I was on a plane and a terrorist
did X or Y, here's I would react.
I don't think we know until we're in these
situations.
I think there's so much in the details and
I wouldn't even pretend to be able to say
definitively what it is that I would do.
Let me know what you think.
If you've been in such a situation I would
be interested in hearing from you.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about something that is happening
within the healthcare field, the healthcare
industry that is not discussed nearly as much
as how we pay for healthcare, Medicare for
all, et cetera, which is huge burnout among
doctors and nurses.
I have some personal stories actually to tell
about this.
We will also talk about a lot of people are
going crazy about this and Joe Rogan tweeted
about it and I tweeted back that I think people
are misunderstanding.
There's a bill that's been proposed in Massachusetts
that would ban the word bitch and people are
going crazy about language policing and all
this stuff.
If you understand what it is that is going
on, you would realize that this is like nothing,
that this shouldn't even be a news story.
And then lastly, a Georgia sheriff started
putting no trick or treating signs in the
yards of sex offenders in advance of Halloween
and the sex offenders are now suing.
We will talk about the legal and the social
and the cultural and the logical when it comes
to that story.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show, the show can continue.
There is more, show a two ways to access it.
Become a
member@joinpacmandotcomorbecomeapatronatpatrion.com
slash [inaudible]
David Pakman show much more coming up on the
bonus show.
Otherwise, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.